Je ne me soucie même plus de nourrir une haute culture
conan thailandais maman thaïlandaise lisbonne na
empile un peu, il n'y a pas de colère là-bas
donner une courbe au ventre et
mit e de horizon's l'amazonie tel
droit à ce qu'ils ont dit et c'était le redondonde
Austin est trop hostile à Tom pour m'avoir
Je voulais que ce soit sec et quand je sors la pagaie
à vendre aux enchères, les lacets Brésil que nous sommes
selon le dn de se admet la justice ou
label Jude Riozinho j'ai utilisé le cercle d'Aldovar
village pour matelas à eau
et là
unibes toujours seulement une histoire d'amour twitter
Luan en prends un à la fois à Porto Vai
tu es venu si tu ne lui as pas fait passer l'examen
examen de pointe là-bas, elle devait le faire
différent et portail et services dans
et là
une affliction de trou en colère unibes
Igrejado regarde ampiezza rythme youtube
[Musique]
au revoir, prépare juste plusieurs liquides viraux
Julio Race mon frère ours religieux et
c'est certainement le cas, je l'ai fait, je l'ai enroulé différemment
cérémonie et je pensais que ce n'était pas le cas
déposer des fichiers sur
le stand le nom en portugais est José
branches de noyer salustiano et chez nous pas
ouais, appelle Jéhovah, n'appelle pas ça, c'est le travail.
peu ici dans ce domaine de l'environnement
comment allons-nous fournir quoi du village
et où nous en sommes ici à l'entrée ici
d'un sont les d'un parc un parc
médicinal que nous allons maintenant
visiter
c'est un projet, le mien est dans le mien
à ma connaissance
renforcement culturel et nous arrivons
j'étudie en prenant du sucre là-bas à l'intérieur du
nature et voyant qu'il est nécessaire de
les gens sont dans la nature avec
sagesse et nous avons utilisé
la façon dont nous avons appris aussi
dans cette connaissance et vient
travaillant de cette façon depuis son là-bas, je
Je pense qu'elle a l'air d'avoir
impuissance à votre goût ou pas
parle un noir seulement au sucre pour nous, elle
c'est un vin très sacré et très
important pour les indigènes onde na onde
nous voyons des gens évoluer
peut se connecter avec la nature
considérait le respect de la nature comme un
être vivant à comprendre que c'est en considérant le
la nature comme notre mère et comme nous
tu vois ici tu vois et je pense que
en est-il un pour la population autochtone en est-il un
j'ai un objet très sacré, très précieux
c'est l'espace que nous avons à l'intérieur
du parc, celui-ci est un arbre
Luan a trouvé le samaúma que les gens qui
des gens pour qui nous avons beaucoup de respect
par l'actionnaire cet arbre qui a un
esprit très fort de la nature et à
nous pour moi pour nous dans la nation elle-même et
lancer le mandala que nous avons
un grand respect de la nature ou
collecte spontanée d'instantanés à un
vitesse de route d'élite pendant le sommeil et
l'euro la trouvera giovana rei salut salut salut som
Je donne quand je donne hahaha
tourisme ou citoyenneté l'examen de
se transformer en pluie municipale quand répéter et
junior la nourriture tourne grâce aux efforts
depuis la porte de partage chakana si appétit
quand ils ont résisté et qu'est-ce que Julia fait laide
toit cette gratitude est ce qui déteste c'était
tu veux en être un, prie pour que je le sois
la princesse assiste décidée à faire en sorte que
ton autre arbre droit, celui du zoo
alcoolique celui-là avec du carrelage reçu
sont des aigles o voici venir en enfer
des affaires comme ça
c'est tellement bonjour, tout ce dont j'ai rêvé en premier
remercier Dieu comme je veux
payez ça, nous facturons ici comme ça
diplôme dans ce leadership par câble 10 vôtre
mère était présente ici à l'intérieur du
travail laissé aux femmes et
les hommes qui l'ont accompagné sont
beaucoup de choses pour nous déconnent
surtout aujourd'hui, il y a beaucoup
contradiction qui agite ces événements
fictif, parle-moi de la terre, nous devons
repartir neuf et à l'abri du currasco mais c'est
un coin doux d'où les lettres et
et là
ferez le football jusqu'à ce que vous le soyez
difficile mais M. chenille juninho
ma grâce de 6 regards d'idée est
en tenant compte du fábio, il y a 700 hôtels de
homicides dans
et là
le résultat o
João est donc tu es tu y vas
son échelle lui appartenait, l'idée n'est pas de le faire
ça tous les jours, pas combien de poissons déjà
ils ont déjà pêché mais ils ne viennent pas aujourd'hui, pas aujourd'hui
nous l'avons sorti de là maintenant ne le démarre pas
J'étudiais dans la partie à la demande
la femme est responsable de la maison sans elle
dans la partie maison comme dans la partie ménage
de la maison pour s'occuper des enfants est plus
cela fait aussi partie de ma responsabilité
c'est s'occuper davantage de la partie recherche, non ?
chercher dans la forêt de la nourriture pour
des gens à nourrir et aussi dans le cadre de
brossé
le temps de ma maison que je fais est
prendre soin de mes enfants, nettoyer mon
maison et nettoyage des vases arrêter de boire
de l'eau et c'est ce que je prends
faire le ménage autour de ma maison donc non
les déchets et les déchets en plastique sont
et depuis que l'autre banane tombe les gens
il joue pendant qu'il chante, il ne mixe pas
tout est là donc je balaie avec le
les garçons beaucoup celui-là, je suis venu parler au
Madame, est-ce que j'ai un nom ou pas ?
appelez ce poêle un poêle en argile et
trop en ajouter n'est pas trop mal car
ça travaille dur, ça ne fait pas que faire du feu
[ __ ] oui là ça marche ça reste ici
l'intérieur n'est pas un
l'alcool si ce n'est pas le téléphone
conduire jusqu'au dernier jour que je connais
elle a depuis renoncé à l'aviron pour se produire
entre les forges pour dire j'aime dormir
pourquoi pas des ateliers au village
la musculation l'a donc tout va bien
Terre
C'est là
et là
être ce qu'il est depuis le trou de la page d'accueil de réglage
minute tu es diamètre sandra forrei
Ana, avant de prier, quelque chose de très gentil
même alors, le projet social que le mot
social et
bonjour, comment vas-tu, je suis Edilson dans la langue
Soldatini portugais achar andava do
les aras, c'est vrai, et je suis professeur ici à
terre indigène il y a 30 ans, alors vous
ça en fait partie intégrante les gens hahahaha et
parle un peu plus de ce type quoi
celui-là te pousse vraiment parce que
il y a tellement d'ethnies, tellement de sauts, he na
Amazon oui, nous avons bien fait une enquête
pour savoir d'où avez-vous utilisé le
de toute façon, qui est ce connard
o et en plus de ces recherches j'ai fait
parler avec les aînés, directement avec les
nos personnes les plus âgées, c'est vrai notre o
notre peuple venait de très peu de choses
deux personnes en fait mon grand-père et mon
grand-mère veut la faveur de Napoléon et Isabelle à l'écoute
qui était ma grand-mère, ces deux personnes qui
J'ai apporté cette graine que j'ai plantée aujourd'hui
nous couvrons déjà près d'un millier
les gens ici dans l'état d'acre donc c'était
cette histoire est très difficile pour nous
les gens achètent parce que notre peuple est un ara
comme une personne très guerrière qui
nous avons eu devant tous la lutte de
peuples autochtones, quand il y avait cela
que cette confrontation avec le
Mon peuple blanc, les banques tuées
ici, faites tout et utilisez toujours les zones
Je l'apporte devant, puis ils ont perdu leur
la force et la fin de la culture et elle a émergé de ces
deux personnes pour planter la graine qui
nous avons aujourd'hui
pour utiliser le ils ont toujours vécu sur cette terre
ils avaient ici, je vais au paradis, c'est vrai
il se voyait là mais à la tête du
frontière avec le droit de vivre là-bas avec le
les patrons blancs sortent de là quand il arrive
je l'ai vu plutôt serré dans une situation
pareil et ils sont venus ici pour le
croisière dans la vallée des neiges, restez ici
passer du temps ici quand tu étais
même de celui-là est sorti et moi au bagé celui
affluent du Tage, c'est très loin
retirez-vous ici par la frontière, n'est-ce pas ?
c'est vraiment une question de faire ça
voyager plusieurs jours avec la même famille
reste là et y vis un moment
Je reviendrais ici et d'ici je reviendrais
arrête encore là, il a toujours vu ça
dans cette pièce, transitant ici vous
tu ne peux jamais partir d'ici pour un autre
région et tu es très bien ici alors
je vis très bien ou ça pourrait être ici dans le
football un jour en ville quand elle
les idées de lasso sont de l'autre côté de l'Amazonie
Non, je ne pense pas, laisse-moi te dire
voici un peu d'histoire comment cela s'est passé
donc pour la première fois quand il n'y avait pas de terre
indigène quand pas dès que quand
funai est apparu, c'est vrai que pouvoir les marquer
terres, nous envoyons tout cela, nous pouvons déjà
descends un peu, nous avons vécu des coupures
seringue à valparaíso, une autre ici à
croisière dans la vallée encore un bagé comme ça
tous dispersés sans terre, l'escargot et le
le patron aimait vraiment le jeter dehors
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit, il est paresseux et je
comme ça, non ?
et puis avec le temps nous avons eu un peuple
ici, ma famille est même partie
pour une croisière plusieurs familles
arriver en croisière sans argent pour ça
en rien, je souffre beaucoup
besoin là-bas à Cruzeiro do Sul na
ville qu'il y avait quand il est apparu ou sur terre
droit autochtone selon lequel il y aurait des terres autochtones
que les Indiens ont des terres et je pars
payer le loyer et vivre dans ce qui était
d'entre eux, c'est qu'ils ont commencé à adhérer, non ?
Funai viendra ici sur le Cruzeiro do Vale
d'être cette réunion était celle-là
je parle de tout là-bas, les gens y vont si
se réunir, c'est vrai, parce que se réunir juste pour
donne-toi un exemple quand nous avons commencé
Ici, dans les années 70, les gens essaient de ne pas t'aimer
mais ici, éteindre même l'écoute n'est pas
il n'y a pas longtemps, il était un enfant moi
Je pense qu'il est né, non ?
ça fait longtemps que ce n'est pas 70n
aujourd’hui, il touche près d’un millier de personnes, n’est-ce pas ?
donc nous avons fait beaucoup de progrès
grand, nous n'avions pas d'éducation, nous n'avions pas
la santé n'avait rien, j'allais comme ça
le fondateur du peuple le plus ancien était
choisi par mon peuple pour enseigner
ici à l'intérieur de la terre indigène mais très
difficile
Je vais vous le dire, c'est très difficile sans
structure sans savoir sans rien, droit de
travail ou quelque chose que nous
nous sommes souvent confrontés à cela cinq fois
la culture si je te dis ce qu'est la culture
nous ne savions pas quelles cultures je mangeais
professeur dans un autre, mon ami est là
un autre jour, c'est qui nous avons ouvert cet espace
qu'aujourd'hui nous voyons notre chay
chant peint prenant à pied chantant
ces gants de mer pour moi
pour moi, c'est un son, pour moi, c'était un
l'espace que nous nous sommes laissé
ouvert que nous avons planté qui est aujourd'hui
porter ses fruits, ici même dans le laps de temps est
ma fille de saint qui l'entoure
fais confiance, profite de demain, je prends ça
est exploité, c'est pareil et mets-le
entreprise que je veux boxer, j'en ai plein
le professeur est allé de la décharge de Serra à pied
cycle de visite que sont les généraux qui
c'est la grande chaise de Ferreira et un aquarium
Amblon de la reine de la fête ou sur terre
[Musique]
quoi
je veux sept mia particulières là-dedans
secteur je l'ai adoré je pense que le se
rassemblés et
Apprenez à connaître Mania Da Water Oil et
Je suis avec toi mon père depuis que j'ai la cl12
donc Huesca Daliane dix ans pour approcher
ensemble profession sexy ma radio et mon rock
Miley est désigné pour le sang de l'organisme
dit un surfeur potentiel chaud et minute
trt-17 où hier le prévisible que
année et quand celui-ci retient le sodium de l'autre
peignage et vin dans
et comptez avec le bon mode de shake
Les roms tournant et Saturne où sont-ils
signer la sonde ce qui est écrit le
dur sur
et là
C'est là
bonjour, je m'appelle regi et je suis emanuelle
Beatriz comme ça met à jour Firjan dans
tout tombe du
l'arrangement fixe où je dore sinon le
mérite de loin minute sertão de
réflexion sur le registraire israélien
J'ai vu alors le doux dépotoir d'Eridon s'ils le sont
Secrétaire israélien pendant Rossi II
et là
et pour mettre le premier, je viens d'aller à
entrer dans le sang lentement
l'adorateur des couleurs pour le meilleur nettoyage
versets je mets mal l'herbe un coup dans le
vieux sauf le dimanche tu lui demandes
la machine de forage de puits de phoque tibétain est
réparation si controversée
et celui-ci dans le tableau pour chasser était
protection, peux-tu en parler un peu, voici
un tableau que nous peignons, c'est nous
est-ce que tu vas faire une activité aussi
quelque chose qui représente un
symbole de la nature qui est une peinture
naturel de c'est d'un fruit et dans la récolte
que nos seniors ont beaucoup de choses comme ça
un fruit qui a beaucoup de valeur sert
pour que cette encre aille à Xin
pour faire peur et à l'équipe tout est très
important chaque fois que nous utilisons oui
Je sais que tout est protégé en étant allé à
demain sur l'île de la maison, c'est mauvais
et là
C'est là
le barbecue a appelé là-bas et autre chose
gentil avec un
et là
C'est là
Je voulais lui envoyer Jorge Gerdau Sa
[Musique]
et là
C'est là
qu'est-ce que c'est a déjà un liquide qui
brûle Jarina, nous avons un like
il y a de l'eau que nous utilisons pour
la nourriture ainsi que les médicaments légers
pour sa main d'insecte aussi toi
je veux cette nourriture
c'est très bien d'avoir une morsure de serpent o
son œil lui sert à combattre le
venin de celui ou venin du serpent qui vient
avoir cette connaissance de tous les os
astral ce qui a survécu dans la forêt
en nourrissant des fruits qui, sans
reste, j'ai un peu de connaissances pour
nous avons l'eau, nous avons tout ce dont nous avons besoin
être dépendant de la rivière des plantes
survivre à
C'est là
et là
et c'est une plante médicinale qui
nous l'utilisons pour en adapter un de plus
peu avec la nature avec la forêt et le
les gens entrent à l'intérieur de ça
médecine que nous pouvons adapter
plus avec la nature, c'est respecter la
la nature en tant qu'être vivant comme ça
il y a des êtres dans la biodiversité
il parvient à respecter en tant qu'être humain
et grâce à ce médicament nous
respecter tous les êtres de la nature est
peux-tu voir la nature comme notre mère
et nous faisons ce travail aujourd'hui
que la médecine ait un grand respect comme
avec la nature et apprenez à les connaître au sein du
notre biodiversité vous pensez
bail et que vous pourrez découvrir vers le sud
Après ça, je lui ai coupé la tête
Guasca c'est ça et c'est comme ça
noix de coco
le pape comprend très bien comment
je peux faire passer cette chose comme si le
esprits dont parler quand vous
à travers cette réunion, il est là et aime
na à travers ça, cette force est-ce
connexion avec laquelle nous pouvons nous connecter
nos esprits de nos
les ancêtres nous parviennent, par exemple pour
les gens apprendront la médecine, il le fera
les gens restent ici matériellement l'esprit
va étudier, va voyager dans la forêt inoxydable
ici c'est matériel mais c'est l'esprit
c'est à l'intérieur de la forêt, c'est à l'intérieur d'un
ailleurs, il apprendra que
prend et cette connaissance que nous avons déjà
je suis revenu avec cette connaissance
que nous pouvons là dans ce coin et
il est donc très important que ce vin
de la nature qui est vivante
et c'est sacré
et là
C'est là
le meilleur jusqu'à sept compositeur de courbes pour moi
ce n'est pas prêt ça se termine et tout est mignon
reçoit le projet dit l'électricien
pour les cultures autochtones et
et celui-ci a perdu un peu de chance
rappi luan tu as écouté celui que je
J'ai réussi, elle est un colibri, un colibri qui
elle a croisé tellement de monde et nous restons
lié à la nature des êtres
de ça va c'est la forêt tout va bien
Je suis en vie, ça ne marchera pas, je pense qu'on
ça reste comme ça là je pense
vraiment, il ressent le pouvoir et son nouveau
la culture se nourrit enfin de mon
celui-ci l'est aussi
ce qui est portugais c'est perruche ou flamenco
qu'est-ce que c'est demain, ne le prends pas
créer est ce que nous voulions
animal de compagnie et
et là
et dans le hall du train, j'ai mesuré ici le propriétaire
Je vais en compagnie et
e-social, il est un enfant très sérieux
voler même si je devais le faire, il te fait
alors elle est stupide, des milligrammes de rue pour moi
il est devant l'option américaine
il est toujours si beau à la fête, non ?
non 10 11 12 13 14 une
et puis va coudre ce que tu veux
sérieusement, je vais prendre une douche maintenant et ça
ce sera pour faire du tapioca pour le
les gens boivent le matin avec du café oui
oui, elle va s'asseoir et je vais verser le
de l'eau puis nous faisons du tapioca à partir de gomme et
comment faire du tapioca enfin demain je
Je vais le prendre pour manger là-bas, différence ici
ou n'est-ce pas
la déesse non oui 60 moi il homme dans la maison
et son patron est le responsable de la maison
dans la famille et le temps où tu es maintenant à toi, il l'était
pour faire de la farine et j'ai pelé et tiré
mais aujourd'hui, il est rentré chez lui et il apportera le
la farine c'est toi c'est lui aussi parce que c'est ça
voici la plante, cette pomme de terre est là
très semblable à ça, comment s'appelle quelqu'un qui aime et
ami et comment s'est passée la vie avec De Na
forêt comme celle-ci ou est-ce que tu vis à l'intérieur
alimentez la fête, enfin l'Amazonie
bonjour, comment ça va ici oui ah c'est bon
la vie à Dieu ne plaise et pourquoi est-ce parce que
que personne, on y allait tranquillement
vieux ici est plus froid et nous avons
personne non seulement comme l'acheté a le
notre nourriture de nous mata da mata et
Maria nous attend des poissons et des plantes
mange tôt pour ne pas acheter et tu as déjà
Je pensais connaître la vérité, c'est tout pour
c'est pour ça qu'elle est là, pas parce que je
Je pense haha ​​​​juste pour une promenade que nous
sors là-bas, reviens et il y en a
des problèmes de temps en temps, pas après tout
non non, je n'en ai jamais eu plus maintenant non
il y a plus, je ne suis pas arrivé maintenant, la farine tombe
se termine à 9h00, je suis toujours sorti de là, je suis déjà
Je suis venu là-bas, j'en ai tué un, j'en ai tué un
emberbill sérieusement, c'est quoi cette phrase
et quel est l'animal qui vit dans la maison de
Larissa là, sa femme là et là à pje o
En cela, le baladeiro est là pour nous tuer
il est là, fille, tu ne l'as pas, je vais passer ou
je ne peux pas passer oui oui oui mais seulement ça
il ne me descend pas là et 62 four là et
c'est fini, c'est parti, ils ne sont pas là
en mesurant là depuis le père là, il est arrivé là
avec un fichier dessus là avec moi là c'est tout
le même gars peut monter pour y aller pour avoir le
travailler à l'intérieur, papa sait bien
[Musique]
l'anniversaire hydratant à peigner
ici, regardez celui-ci, c'est que le
les gens bougent comme ça, regardent ici pour sécher
il va faire très chaud là-bas alors
comment et comment allons-nous
mettez le feu ici, ce qui est un
faire la comparaison
et à quoi ressemble
C'est là
quel évier passe, manque le manioc oui
puis on le sort d'ici, pierre, on le met
nous à l'intérieur de cela à l'intérieur de cela
sac ici mis là dans ce sac
puis on met des bâtons dessus
d'ici en haut là la cuisse ici jusqu'à là dans le
la côte doit sécher à partir de là
artistique d'y jouer vu que c'est pour
remuer pour sécher, vous connaissez cette farine pour
de la nourriture à faire pour nous
vendre pour acheter du sel ou du sucre
du savon, ces choses, tu sais que nous
la farine fait vendre pour acheter
ce zap, nous le devons à tous
porto Velho porto walter et ici aussi
de toute la mer qui est là-haut passe
ici, nous lui vendons
attache ici, eh bien, moche
penser ici et nous lui vendons le
fais tout juste moi mais mes enfants qui
on a fait ça, c'est très beau, non, mais pour
même en le recouvrant, nous avons fait les murs
du four, c'est vrai, j'ai mis les planches du
four où on met la farine
séchez celui-ci ici, prenez-le de là autant que le
Dry Edithvale joue ici là-dedans
alors jette-le ici, le sac était à moi
son frère est à lui, puis il a brûlé là-bas après
brûlé et c'est tout, le voilà sur la clôture pour
créer un jardin où tout est des pommes de terre d'ici
que je vais retirer pour que vous puissiez voir merci
papaye très gentille épouse papaye
magnifique ici
Je peux aussi m'attendre à ce que toute la montée soit
un silence que tu ne peux pas manger, ce n'est pas juste
toi ainsi que la plupart des choses
Ce n'est pas vrai, la forêt n'est pas ah ah, c'est possible
Je pourrais survivre sans rien, ne signe pas
l'aide est là ou pas non non je ne sais pas
rien, nous ne pouvons pas, nous ne pouvons pas rire, non
qui ne meurt pas de faim mais qui doit le faire
plante-le pour que nous puissions survivre
Je suis sorti de la forêt, je n'ai pas et
ça suffit si tu ne plantes pas, tu n'as pas
il n'y a pas celui là on plante ok sinon
déployer et ne pas avoir à venir ici
Tu vois, il y en a beaucoup ici, n'est-ce pas, la papaye
on s'échange la main la banane le manioc c'est vrai
c'est à partir d'ici que nous fabriquons la farine, c'est vrai aussi
ici, tu y es déjà allé, tu n'as pas vu
et puis Pedro attends là c'est la patate toi d'ici
qu'on va fariner pierre et de
aboie-en un, comment on s'appelle, alors c'est tout
le manioc et
c'est très beau pep c'est nous nous les aras
nous seulement, nous n'avons qu'une seule ethnie au Brésil
nous existons seulement, nous ne sommes pas comme les autres
des ethnies que Hitachi ne considère pas comme uniques
il y a d'autres nids qui en ont plus, c'est vrai, mais
nous non nous, il n'y a qu'un seul peuple d'aras dans le
Le Brésil n'en a pas d'autres ni d'autres
sais-tu que s'il sortira, il n'y a qu'un seul peuple d'aras
qu'est-ce qu'on est ici, là-bas, nous a amené comme ça
au début, nous étions plus le premier était
plus en savent mais d'autres les autres
nous y avait mis fin et non
c'est fini parce que je suis notre ceux qui sont restés
ils ont couru en voulant te tuer je pense
c'est parce qu'il y en avait, je pense que c'est parce que non
J'ai aimé le peuple Macaw, non ?
désir de finir d'être seul avec lui
même droit
c'est pourquoi je le dis comme ça parce que le
ma mère me disait tu sais alors
c'est pire que nous comme tu peux le voir
c'est vrai, les Arara parlent le plus souvent dans le
en portugais, c'est vrai parce qu'il n'y en a pas beaucoup
les anciens que j'ai vus, c'est vrai, c'était
C'est ce dont je parle
ils sont morts, c'est vrai, et ce qui restait des
les personnes âgées qui sont encore en vie
ont un peu honte d'enseigner à
nous savons aussi pourquoi ce n'est pas parce qu'il
Pensez-vous que vous n'aimez pas enseigner ?
car aujourd'hui il y a d'abord les
indiens bibbia cais uma, né a cais uma
à base de manioc, leur nourriture
bibiu le matin passe là le passé
le travail arrive à 11 heures, endure juste
avec des lunettes d'ici sur le devant de
manioc Billy le matin et puis
j'arrive juste à 11 heures fortes de la même manière
c'est vrai, une bonne nourriture pour donner ça
manioc qui était sur le quai
et c'est comme ça que nous vivons d'abord tu sais
aujourd'hui, nous le voyons aussi comme ça
la culture est ce qui tient la nôtre
débarquer notre tradition notre culture
radis buco do chão da un são paulo eu
J'ai bien décidé les gars le culte de Napoléon et
intérêt et je ne sais tout simplement pas si la diode est pour la création
de leader de la même arrivée au
papier sur
et pendant que vous me dites un petit monsieur de
quand tu fais des erreurs comme ça plus jeune quand
tu es le jeune comme ça ah je ne sais pas tu as 90 ans
il y a comment faire des erreurs dans la vie à quoi ressemblait la vie
et en tant que radio, aha, faites-moi plaisir
fais-moi savoir quand tu en auras un
et comment prendre la vie là où elle a souffert
univers tu es difficile là-bas expansion
travaille si tu jettes le butin de Tomás
Donc, je n'habitais pas là-bas, j'y vivais aussi
je vivrai ici pour guérir en regardant
maintenant, mon fils, ton placement allait
allons-y, nous ne voulions pas aller plus loin
nous allions chez l'autre patron, je l'ai fait, na
conduire après c'était que nous arrivions à
ici, regarde-moi un peu plus, c'est vrai, c'est lui
demander, c'est parce que la culture dès le
notre peuple, le bœuf a perdu, c'est vrai et pourquoi
beaucoup de jeunes d'aujourd'hui ne savent pas
notre discours est pourquoi tu pars
être né un
le nouveau style m'a appris plus, c'est vrai, mon père m'a appris
Je suis arrivé, ton père m'a appelé, je ne l'ai pas raté
Je ne l'ai pas perdu, c'était une femme
repose-toi aujourd'hui, voici Lia go
Même parler portugais ne paie pas plus pour
enlève ses sous-vêtements avec une fille, c'est pourquoi
perdu si ces gens, beaucoup ont perdu
et c'est maintenant le jour où c'est comme ça, non ?
tu sais, n'est-ce pas ?
oh et pourquoi monsieur parce qu'elle est les parents
n'apprend pas à les mettre aujourd'hui je ne sais pas moi
il jure mais il ne parle pas, il ne parle pas
mais il ne dit pas que les gens avaient honte
pour parler de la culture, hein, les plus jeunes
c'est parce que j'ai vu le personnel qui dit ça
il suffit de le chercher et il y avait
honte et parle de la tournée dans notre
la honte c'est la honte
g1
bien et parce que tu sais parce que tu as une idée
parce que c'est dommage, je ne sais pas
J'étais dans le sang et
et là
et souviens-toi que tu consommes ton fils
détends Jupiter pour l'idée pomme
on dirait déjà un détecteur de chance de poisson
j'ai entendu parler d'eux qui riaient fort en vacances
d'avoir et des abdos qu'il connaît qui permettent au
Le chariot de Celia, j'ai été stupide
J'ai dit le meilleur que j'avais, c'est que les filets se soulèvent
quand c'est dangereux et
le x dis quelque chose les filles que vous êtes
heureux de vivre ici ou pas et pourquoi
très beau parce que c'est bon
et il se peut qu'elle reste là-dedans, qu'elle
ne joue pas
un sac de réveil et de plaisanterie, c'est si bon
et il y a aussi une réplique qui est bonne mais pas
il ne fait pas très chaud de temps en temps non
seulement tu pars
salut Daiane j'appelle Ana Luiza oncle radio
suis
oh et toi, j'avais le lit, pas ce mâle
J'étais au bord de la rivière sans électricité
appel croisé par saveur caboco
j'appelle là j'appelle je suis aussi moi
appelle heia heia était au bord de la rivière
sans pouvoir traverser j'ai appelé
caboclo caboclo chaman dalla je veux appeler
J'ai appelé, j'ai appelé, j'ai appelé et j'appellerai Arreia
J'étais au bord de la rivière sans électricité
traverser et appeler Pedro caboclo caboclo
J'ai déjà appelé le bébé, hé hé Pedro
dis que j'ai aussi appelé et j'appellerai
et ai ai ai ai serra ashanti unissez-vous ici à
lune que de copier combien je dors
C'est moi qui ai dit que ce n'était pas ça
et là
salut et qu'est-ce que c'est parce que les gens
toujours le football qu'il serait, il non
fait une erreur est le meilleur avenir possible pour tante
Salut, c'est le meilleur avenir qui soit
les gens verront que grâce à notre héritage,
celui que ma grand-mère a laissé pour aller à celui-là
les gens appellent Dalla qui est ton secours
culturel vos mythes et c'est là que nous
ça pourra l'être, c'est une graine qui
elle l'a laissé ici aujourd'hui est en train de germer
pour que les générations futures le sachent
une partie de ce travail que je ne peux pas
terminer, puis-je continuer, alors c'est un
un travail très important pour l'avenir
la génération fait partie de la sécurité de
notre terre est notre identité culturelle
et ils ont aussi fait celui-ci
connaissance de ce travail
le bébé aussi et finalement voilà
même sens de l'intervalle dès que le
je suis vraiment attaché à la mère en tant qu'être humain
un être vivant ou une chose une image un
petit
oh va te faire [ __ ], c'est vraiment dans l'autre
le truc, c'est qu'on l'appelle comme une mère, comme la
simple respect de la considération à l'intérieur
de ce qui existe en elle, c'est que le
on voit que seule une mère prend bien soin d'un
fils, comme ça, c'est par exemple nous
nous avons ici la nature pour
forêt et on y va par exemple
donc il n'y a pas d'arbres ici si
donner un veto ou c'est au milieu, d'accord ?
la forêt attrape d'abord dans la forêt un
la forêt est déjà venue ici, fais attention là-bas
quand j'arrive, nous y sommes déjà
d'abord et la forêt combat ensuite le
les gens, c'est parce que de l'eau que nous avons
de la nature des plantes pour arroser la rivière à
la nourriture donc il n'y a aucun moyen de
les gens ne le considèrent pas comme un
mère, où est tout ce qu'il y a pour que nous puissions aller
le jackson soit le bénéficiaire des villages
redémarrage du club xau offense la blague
embrasse un son puis émet un son emmène-le avec
voyant recevoir ajouté il m'appelle da
wow, j'étais nu de cette récolte sécurisée, c'est
heureusement baiser oncle rui a
salut salut salut la course a a a a
le poêle série B
C'est là
et puis les indiens chantaient en se souvenant du
petite amie sait avoir une petite amie
là, je chante en disant à propos de mes copines que
j'avais l'habitude de dîner là-bas, hein
salut et le matin matin matin mer et demain
va demain voir les ordures il est tombé sur son visage
Coco la soeur yo queiro hirohito chuio va
soeur ar o cuiabá ce n'était pas moi et la mère
maman aime c'est mauvais et la voiture et la voiture
rejeter et diffuser le pouvoir du collier de ma chère sœur
et demain demain demain demain demain
demain demain demain demain demain mon
sœur
l'argent qui va à ma sœur qui le porte
produit j'adore entendre la Wii U Rayman
et demain demain demain demain demain maman
c'est mauvais là-bas de présenter un papa, j'y vais
sortir n'est pas